foreign
[Music]
environmental threats to our people
climate change pollution and loss of
biodiversity prevent development
80 of the sustainable development goals
will not be achieved if biodiversity is
not protected
once again
the average surface temperature of our
planet will increase by more than 1.5
degrees
we must not look away because this is an
irreversible
points
must fight against them we must act
together and through Partnerships
Partnerships Association developed
emerging and developing countries all
working on the same um
but also financial and economic actors
Civil Society including conservation
International
leader in the system
because through a better coordination of
beneficiary countries while meeting the
needs of other countries
Partnerships for Just Energy transition
known as jet P
can become a model of sustainable
development for Partnerships
to enable a gradual exit from fossil
fuels they mobilize both public and
private funding
many of you are piloting these
strategies
in South Africa which continues to grow
will be with us today
foreign
financing of our common ambitions
Mr President thank you very much
I want to thank you very much I welcome
this opportunity
to be on this panel and to be in this
Summit as well
and re-participate here with uh
the full hope that this panel or this
Summit will add on to a number of
processes that we need to
and back upon to enlarge and broaden our
own experiences the world
but it should not be seen as replacing
what we are all doing at the
multilateral
organization's level in other words we
should still remain centered around what
we are doing in institutions of the UN
so this Summit should add on to that and
yes bring about an influence but should
not proceed and seek to influence
negatively those those processes
South Africa as most of you will know we
did arrive at a deal the jet P deal with
a number of countries
and we found this to be a pioneering
deal quite historic
in that an amount of 8.5 billion dollars
was committed to support our transition
to clean energy
which as South Africa we had preceded by
coming out with a very bold plan where
we realized that we've got to embark on
this journey
and there are quite a number of lessons
that we are learning as we are moving
ahead I will just maybe share five the
first one is that a plan like this
on the
country's challenges and experiences it
should never be imposed on any country
in our case we've had to take into
account our own experience as a nation
and as a country where we are dealing
with challenges such as unemployment and
poverty and also dealing with the
history of division in our own country
of racial Division and all that so any
plan of this nature that helps the
country to Transit needs to take in to
account the circumstances of any country
that is going through this type of plan
the second one is we've had to say this
should be a just transition it must
take into account the existential
situation of various communities
particularly workers who work in fossil
fuel
establishments what happens to them when
we transit to their job situations
communities who live in those areas so
all that needs to be taken into account
and any country that embarks on this
journey must Define what a just
transition is going to be and what it is
going to look like
so that whatever is done should not
leave anyone behind
in fact we should see a situation where
you
test will be established and people will
be taken along
the
third one is that we need to be flexible
it needs to be a flexible type of
Journey
right now in our own country we have
learned as we've been
traversing this path
that we've got to take into account our
current challenges and our current
challenges are born out of the history
of our own country but also they have to
deal with our energy uh shortage right
now uh of 90 of our energy is generated
out of fossil fuels
and right now the country is going
through a major energy challenge because
our energy generation is way below the
needs of the of the country at the
moment
so we've said that as we Transit as we
implement this jet P we need to take
into account that and some of our fossil
fuels power stations will need to remain
in existence as we are traversing this
journey so it is important that that
should be taken into account the other
one of course the major one is the
finance part
what
we did after making our clear bold
statement as well as after reaching this
jet uh P deal and having been offered
8.5 billion in the form of grants in the
form of concessional loans and in a form
of plain vanilla loans we found that
actually we're going to need
a much more up to 98 billion dollars
Which is far much more than what has
been on offer so therefore we therefore
need access to funding and the funding
has to be innovative
funding has to increase on the grant
size and also the concessional loans
also needs to be considerable
and where we have gone to now is that we
have found great understanding from our
partners
about our situation uh recently just
yesterday I had the prime minister of
Denmark and the Netherlands visiting our
country at the same time
and they made commitments being very
much alive to all the circumstances that
we face so we are encouraged by that
because all this this journey requires
partnership and the partnership must be
active it must be a partnership that
takes into account where we are but it
must also be a partnership that is
willing to commit to a future that will
lead to Fed so that's where we are in
the lessons we are learning are ongoing
almost every day we learn lessons what
we've had to do is also to set up a
commission that brings everyone every
important stakeholder in the country
together so I've set up a presidential
climate change commission which brings
scientists academics trade unions
government people are both at local
government level provincial and at
National level so all of us participate
in this type of debate and it's becoming
a very rich debate because nearly
everyone participates it's not just
government
imposing its own will and wishes on our
people so everybody sees in a very
transparent way what we are seeking to
to achieve and so that in the end
ensures that no one is Left Behind and
we walk this journey together so that's
the lessons that we can put out for
everyone to hear
thank you for your words Mr President
thank you and we're quite happy to see
that the nations are joining the jetp
and thank you for reminding everyone
also that any transition must be a just
transition and take the local conditions
uh fully in charge
president
of the news
what about your country and your vision
foreign
two topics for you Mr President
let me first of all
warm thanks to president macron
the floor and everyone indeed who has
spoken
I would like first of all
different aspects of this topic I'd like
to give you Egypt's opinion and then
the efforts which we are unrolling and
the measures
I'd like first of all to say that I
thank Mr macron very much for having me
Summit in the context of this crisis
which has been going on for more than
three years
and this has had a very real impact on
the world as a whole
um
particularly sensitive for developing
countries
this also
yeah there's a threat everything in
these countries have been able to do and
consolidate in recent years
therefore to work together to meet the
needs of development countries
have a more robust
response to our different challenges the
climate which we are not the main
Fitness is responsible for but we are
the first ones
but I can say here today that the scope
of the problem
and all the associated challenges
will have to lead us to search for
Solutions
either nationally
in terms of fair transition and
sustainable development which of course
I would like to mention that is
scientific factors and able to meet
energy needs
as a result
the green growth
we have carried out in Egypt
and water food and energy
foreign
[Music]
agreement goals to be met
foreign
feel different
International problems in Egypt
uh children's health program that was
launched in 2016 and in this effort
together with the IMF has allowed us to
meet many of our goals
we have a six percent Improvement
overall
if we continue along this path we should
meet our world
all this on the basis of our reform
oriented programs unfortunately the
pandemic and also the invasion of
Ukraine I've had a very negative impact
on our projects
now
I have flies
[Music]
middle income countries
other problems as well
this foreign
suspend
Ed
to emphasize sustainable development
Elizabeth
um
climate change
in the context of the Paris
agreements
[Music]
transform the energies
will protect the environment
transform these areas in a way that
correspond to our environmental needs
this is quite a great foreign
[Music]
direction now
understanding
from our partners
International financial institutions
and here I think I speak not only for
Egypt from other countries that have the
same problems thank you very much
I am turning toward you could you tell
us perhaps the way in which the
commission can support energy transition
programs but also the fight against
deforestation in favor of biodiversity
especially with the global gateway and
where we stand with the carbon Market
we know gives rise to interest sometimes
questioning
um
first of all I really want to commend
you for inviting and starting this
Summit of global financing new global
financing pact it is up absolutely time
that we do that and many very
fascinating initiatives are around this
Summit here but I want to contribute
with three points indeed the first one
has already been mentioned this is
global gateway
this is our 300 billion investment
program from the European Union for
investment abroad
and we've been speaking a lot about it
of course one of the Prime projects is
the jet p in South Africa
we have Jack piece in Indonesia in
Vietnam as of today in Senegal
there it is these jet PS are for the
transition to renewable energy but we
also have Forest Partnerships as you
said it Zambia Uganda Congo for example
and we have the Partnerships and the
global gateway Investments for example
in green hydrogen just signed at cop27
in charmel Sheikh
important is here
this is funding from the European level
but as you heard from the different
projects a team Europe approach so also
the member states are contributing and
it's not only about funding very
important is also the knowledge transfer
for example as you mentioned the
Skilling and upskilling of the workforce
or when it comes to vaccines the
knowledge about mRNA vaccines for
example I'll stick here to climate
because that's the topic of the summit
but just as an example
another very important factor is that
the global gateway of course is
de-risking
for private capital and this is creating
a conducive environment for private
investors we need the private capital
and this I think is one of the main
themes of this Summit and therefore my
second element is looking at the
question how can we attract more private
investment in climate Finance
for the emerging markets and the
developing economies that's the core
subject that we have to deal with today
and I would like to present here my
second Point our new green Bond
initiative
because
um as I said the the the problem for
emerging market and developing economies
is to have access to Capital markets
without this access to the Capital
Market without this exit access to the
Pension funds the assets managers
emerging markets and developing
economies will not get the funding
needed to make this transition and
public money alone will not be able to
to come up with the solution
therefore
we've looked at what are the attractive
Capital markets element and of course
green bonds are vital to help any kind
of country
to develop uh the or to to push forward
with the green transition and to invest
in the infrastructure needs but
if you look at the developing markets
and the emerging economies then we see
that there are some stumbling blocks
basically on the side of the countries
that want to issue the green bonds we
see a lack of expertise it's a new
market element
but also on the investor side we see
that most asset managers and Pension
funds do not really are not really well
informed about these interesting markets
and therefore too little is done and
they hesitate what we even see is with a
global slowdown and the rising interest
rates that investors are starting to
pull out even of these markets and
economies so last year we saw a pulling
out of 70 billion dollars from emerging
bond funds so we really have to address
these issues
now our idea is our offer is
that we first of all share
directly expertise and know how how you
develop these green Bond markets nobody
issues more green bonds than the
European Union
we had to learn it too we've stepped up
massively in the last years but it was a
learning process so we want to share
this knowledge this is very important
and also give technical assistance and
expertise to build up such a market the
second part is of course we also have to
push the investor side and therefore we
want to financially support the
de-risking for the investors this is the
first entry the first open door to go
into these markets and here together
with the eib and the development Finance
institutions of member states we are now
committing 1 billion euros basically to
give private investors the certainty
they need to step up their Investments
and this could attract around 15 to 20
billion dollars of sustainable
investment that's the second element
the third element
is something new where we still have to
work very hard on the green bonds exist
already as a market and this is the
topic of carbon pricing
carbon pricing is one of the most
effective if not the most effective tool
to cut emissions
in a way that nudges the polluters the
industry the traffic
Mobility sector building sector
either if they continue to pollute to
pay for the pollution or and this is the
interesting part not just the
participants into innovation
and emission trading or carbon pricing
so put a price on carbon greenhouse gas
emissions
has as a consequent that people decide
do I want to pay for it no I prefer to
innovate and go into the clean Direction
we have made a very good experience with
that in the European Union just to give
you a figure
we started to introduce carbon pricing
in 2005 lots of learning learn learning
processes had to be done successes and
less good years but if you look back now
throughout the whole period
there were revenues from carbon pricing
of
142 billion euros
and at the same time emissions went down
CO2 emissions went down by 35 so both
goals you want to have you want to have
emissions go down and there are revenues
now we are extending the emission
trading on buildings and Road Transport
and what we have introduced Anew is that
we say the revenues have to go 100 Into
Climate issues and here a fair share
should go to climate Finance abroad
but this is only the European Union the
initiative I wanted to propose is that
we look at Global carbon pricing because
that could of course generate much much
more funding that could then go and it
is a private money that could then go
into
into the climate finance that we need so
badly and here again
two figures
how much of the global greenhouse gas
emissions are covered by carbon pricing
right now only four percent only four
it's almost nothing but these four
percent have already
um generated last year 55 billion dollar
so it's really worth to think about how
could we increase the level of carbon
pricing for example in the highly
developed countries if we take the G20
they have 80 percent of greenhouse gas
emissions
if we only cover for example sixty
percent of the greenhouse gas emissions
with carbon pricing you can imagine what
could be generated and how much
investment this could liberate to go
into uh climate Finance
so
um global gateway exists green bonds are
on a good way carbon pricing we still
have to work a lot but the proposal is
fully aligned with a challenge that
Canada did on carbon pricing and I think
it's really worse to look into it thank
you
thank you
[Applause]
how can we build a strong enter